yeah yeah
too that was a that was a funny yeah
that was an ERA Peewee too yeah PeeWee
Longway yeah and he don't get enough uh
they probably get him on credit man he's
supposed to get a lot more credit he was
hard Scooter's hard too he'll be on that
boot and not like huh be on that boot
and not like
say what
to be on the boot in my life it back in
days [__]
we should be on the boot in Nightline
we went over there please explain okay
so Molly
oh okay so yeah so the Molly be running
around the lobby forever
you just be running around on Molly
bad a little man back in no day let me
see back in the book day the bank order
we probably use list two probably
goddamn future
Bloody Jay
PeeWee Longway
amigo
never really they're really bad
never really about it for real for real
airplanes some other [__] that was
from Atlanta but
um they probably was a plus side [__]
so we're gonna fall down we're gonna
keep it going oh yeah what's that yeah
what's it like uh to to because I've
never done Molly yeah I've only done
shrooms and I've only I smoke weed and I
drink
no Molly ever in my life yeah
is Molly on like sex with Molly is it
indeed better
where from the strong no no just like
from being sober like having sex on a
Molly Isn't all it's you know kind of
cut up to be because you always
[__] no one else back in the day back in
the day you wouldn't [__] on a Model
yeah yeah how was it [__] it was very it
was
foreign
[Music]
have you ever done a honey pack a hand a
pet yeah
from the gas station
no they work great they do this is also
a great opportunity y'all make sure you
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and sign up
for a month a free blue true which is
the same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form delivered to
your door
shout out to Bluetooth they're dick
pills they're our sponsor oh what the
[__] it's a [__] y'all getting
sponsored by the dick of course
um it's a good bag and it's a very very
I don't know you know I don't know
nobody needs I drink a lot of water
you've never been so [__] up after the
club that you just know
like damn I'm drunk like there's head
don't get you hard yeah but you be drunk
you can't go all the way like you might
be able to get it okay
that's it
oh [__]
[Music]
did you say that wet mouth yeah yeah
you've had a girl who doesn't have a wet
nose oh no
look here now look here man
uh anyway
shout out to uh to the wet Mouse out
there yeah man shout out to the wet
Mouse out though are you in a
relationship
single
undisclosed
my whole life as I disclose you do a
good job of being undisclosed yeah